dans cette ville ou dans l'ombre propice
de la nuit quelqu'un est à la recherche
de sarah connor sarah connor oui
sarah connor âgé de 35 ans a été
sauvagement exécutés chez des martyrs et
qu'est ce que c'est un deuxième cadavre
ça va louise conner pas possible vous
donneront d'autres détails sur ces
meurtres notre prochain journal
elle ne le sait pas encore mais c'est
elle qui détruit les besoins de la
suivante de l'onu est toujours sur
répondeur qu'est ce que tu fous qu'on
changeait pas c'est pas toi de toi il ya
un homme qui n'arrête pas de me suivre
personne ne pourra la sauver
ce enfants
je vais vous sauver même il souhaite
vous protéger j'ai deux programmés pour
extermination
je deviens folle tu l'as tuée comment
va-t-il se relever ce n'est pas un homme
c'est une machine d être comme ça ça
n'existe pas c'est vrai bravant 40 ans
tu veux dire que tu vieillis du futur
ils sont là pour se battre
celle dont dépend leur avenir
pourra-t-elle être sauvé et ce
terminator pause pouvoir arriver à aller
entre le mécanisme de son ennemi est
venu pour la sauver
j'ai traversé le temps pour toit zara
l'autre pour la supprimer
arnold schwarzenegger le terminator
une apparence humaine mais un corps
d'acier
jean
invulnérable il n'est programmée que
pour tuer je ne suis pas sarah connor
est l'enjeu d'une bataille de titans
l élu qui secure des sabres a t-elle au
terminator
un film autre que c'est que vous avez vu
jusqu'à présent arnold schwarzenegger et
le terminator